can everyone can everyone hear me
just gonna wait until i have
confirmation
okay
i think we're up
hi everyone uh how's the audio first off
you can hear me okay
all right good well i'm just eating i'm
just having a casual
morning celebrating
100k it's been a while honestly since uh
i've done a stream so
this is a bit nerve-wracking i think the
last time we had a stream was um
[Music]
was it 25k or something like that we i
know we the last one we had was in
october
so um
so thanks everyone for showing up hi
david
um
thanks everyone for being here um
this means a lot
uh to have everyone here and to talk uh
i just want to do a little bit of a
casual you know chat just kind of talk
about life talk about
um
you know where the channel's been where
it's going i really
last stream was halloween day i believe
yeah because i worked that night hey
thanks ben i appreciate that
um
hey thank you
chug been watching around the start
congratulations my friend i like your
analysis of real time thank you very
much
um
yeah that's that's really
50 holy [ __ ] um
thank you very much that's very kind and
i'm you know
i'm very happy that the wheel of time
video is is done i was kind of like
sitting on that for a long time so
hello everyone hi i'm eating cereal yeah
i hope you guys don't mind just kind of
i forgot to eat
so i didn't sleep last night because i
was posting
editing the video and working on that
um
i peaked with the wallet vid honestly i
did i did peek with the wallet vid um
that's really nice thanks for saying
that um
i'm glad people
uh people do that late morning ps4 yeah
you know i feel like on the west coast
i'm always behind everyone um
what thing i am carrying while i'm
carrying cereal and actually you guys
are gonna be really disappointed about
the brand that i'm eating because it's
nothing fun or exciting i'm literally
eating
life cinnamon
yeah
[Laughter]
it's really soggy now because i was
rushing to get everything set up
we're going to have a visit don't worry
we're having an important visit from
the famous woman carrying man she's just
getting ready
um
thoughts on the 2008 financial crisis
thank you for bringing this up i have
actually my next video my ex my next
long-form video is on this exactly so
thank you um
i i think i've never had this many
people in in chat at once so this is
really crazy and cool um
you've been here since 500 subs that's
crazy i mean
it feels like i was just at
five i mean does it feel like i'm at
100k or anything it doesn't feel that
much different it just it's like a lot
more
people which is which is cool
uh i've that's an obvious statement
doesn't really mean anything
um
yeah so nadia is going to be joining us
later to talk a little bit about how
she's had to deal with me over the the
years
doing this channel now
um
but before we dive in
i have not read the poppy war actually
um
i've picked it up yeah i've picked up
don quixote and then i put it down
because it's really heavy um but i'm
gonna read it actually
i love you please say it back i i love
you
and i will say i love you to whoever
does because i'm just i'm that kind of
person who who needs that validation in
the first place so
what's my favorite food god that's crazy
all right i'm getting ahead of myself
what the hell all right i'm answering
questions what i need to do is first off
lay some groundwork for the string so
uh first off we're gonna just be doing
some casual questions uh second off the
second section and this is probably
gonna be like an hour and a half at most
we'll see you love my forehead what the
hell okay i keep getting distracted
because i just like these um
i'm glad someone likes it
um oh all right crate oh and in french
cool um
so thank you everyone for being here so
we're just gonna do some casual
questions hanging out at first and then
we're going to
um maybe i should have thought ahead
about this then maybe we're going to
talk a little bit if you all are
interested in
the wheel of time video i put out if if
anyone has any questions or just kind of
talk about how that went and then i want
to
just talk about where the the channel is
heading because i think i'm at like a
weird stage right now where i'm doing a
lot of
short form stuff and then
i like doing long video essays now i
thought that was pretty fun
it was actually very stressful but it
was fun too
um so we can talk about that and um
and then yeah we're gonna have nadia on
and you can ask her any of your probing
questions about our um
romantic history
if you want um
oh i'm glad
all right so first i need to say thank
you to everyone who's here thank you to
my patrons i'm going to um i want to
list all your names at some point in the
stream i'm extremely grateful for
everyone um i want to thank several um
youtubers who have been who are the
reason why i'm at this stage that would
be
you know who it is daniel green the
goblin uh literally
um
you know reached out to my channel when
i was at like 200 something subscribers
and said hey i like your content
continue doing it
just uh
a lot of a lot of your favorite
youtubers are actually very kind people
in the in in real life and um so that
was the kind of motivation that that i
needed and he's just been incredibly
supportive to the channel i just cannot
thank him enough really really really
wonderful person for real for real um
oh what's this hello
orthodoxy i'm paying for you to read up
until god emperor of june please check
in and give us your two cents
yes
um i promise you i will um full
disclosure i'm almost a college graduate
i'm this is my last quarter and i've
had very little time to read outside of
my uh requirements i'm an english major
so i read a lot all the time um
so i'm definitely going to be reading up
on more of these series so that's what
you can expect when i graduate
because we're at 100 000 subscribers
because we're at this level i'm going to
be putting like my full time into into
this channel
and um i'm really excited i've just been
dying to do that because i feel i've oh
i felt very constrained a bit
by by just uh having to
work and uh do school all the time so um
yeah oh hi
um
what is this your mustache look like
looks like two cappy bars about to kiss
hey that's cool i don't mind that that's
that's pretty cool
degree in youtube literature analysis
wanna play among us okay there's so many
questions i promise you i'm gonna get to
the questions don't worry and i'm
scanning them right now
how old am i good question i turned 25
this year
yeah
i'm 24 right now i turned 25 in august
um
nothing not i'm not having an
existential crisis or anything about it
um
i could talk about favorite movies yeah
so i do want to thank daniel green i
want to thank um the um
booktube community in general the
wonderful people that have just reached
out to me and been really kind
supportive of the channel the booktube
community i'm really happy that i
started the channel within the booktube
community i know that it's kind of
stretched further out than that
um
but i'm really happy to be a part of it
and and to have started that way because
it's just a really kind
uh unit and people are very supportive
there's not a lot of negativity for the
most part so i'm really grateful for
that
um
max says where are your ears in the
thumbnail
max that's
quite a question and thanks for the the
generosity there um
you know that's a good question i did
the fisheye lens on my camera because i
was just trying to look as distorted as
possible and i hope that it came through
because i just i think that's fun and i
like i like when i like when goofy image
you know i'm very simple i think as you
people have probably figured out by
watching my stuff you know that i'm i
might my my sense of humor is very very
down low it's very uh it's not very
elevated
um and in fact i resent people who are
who use clever humor than look down upon
the the working class i'm a working
class humor kind of guy
that's really
that's really crazy 25 you look young
thank you oh the dogs are excited i
think they're they have to make an
appearance um
i don't look young i look old as [ __ ]
sorry
i do kind of um
all right so let's
jake is becoming the skit yeah it is
kind of ironic i guess i'm kind of at
the stage of um getting the blue yeti
and uh talking about tax evasion
i did not i don't evade my taxes i swear
um
no but really i don't um
hey honey they're making so much noise
no you don't have to
just come on stream what are you doing
what are you waiting for are you ready
are you ready
only if you're ready
all right everyone
oh my god all right everyone get ready
for
nadia
and the doggies hold on dogs
there they are just being goofy yes
um
how many people are on we've got 293 oh
wow yeah that's way long i know
hold on i want you guys to see the dogs
[Laughter]
buddy literally loves having his sweater
on like he's obsessed with it like he we
people are like why do you put clothes
on your dogs like you don't understand
he's like he's like the happiest boy
yeah it's because he was a stray dog and
before that he was actually abused so i
think he had so little in his life
before we adopted him that he just
boards clothes and he just loves it it's
a safety net so
uh yeah sedona hates it which is why she
doesn't really have it on a lot of times
unless she's shivering so yeah oh david
hey thanks oh thanks man
so well deserve covered humans
thank you david that's very nice and if
you guys have not subscribed to david
destro it's such an underrated booktuber
please go check out his channel i've
known him for
a long time now we started out so we oh
do you want to have a bite of that yeah
is it the milk it is i'll just have the
milk
just kind of sip milk
all right
um
so thanks everyone and
max what is your opinion about weezer
jake is a weezer
i literally have no i'm sorry i've never
i have zero opinions about weezer i
actually have the worst music of taste
in the world like i have zero music
taste i listen to like
classic rock
you know i like the beatles
yeah i have i have the better music
taste she does
i have a very i like gordon lightfoot
yeah i like canadian folk music he was
born like 50 years ago nice clickbait
you are clearly aging
so we do we continue
no i don't think so actually
um but
you know we do
wait i wonder how long daniel will be
ignored is daniel in the chat i can't
i don't think we need to like we're
actually getting a cat
okay
there it is
i'm sorry i'm very disoriented at the
moment not just because i got uh two
hours of sleep but because i've never
seen the chat kind of move this fast
while we've been live so this is hey
guys should we wax jake's mustache live
can you go
on
do you like books be honest
i'm just gonna not answer that
um i have to be honest and yeah i do
like i hate
i i hate to be that guy you know who
reads
but i do read i like it a lot i'm
actually very passionate about it
believe it or not
i also write too which cringe i know
he is the most fantastic
writer
how little can i pay you to distract you
from your point pretty much that much
that's pretty much what how much you can
pay to distract me from my point so
um
yeah um max hearing my name because
someone else named max donated is a
confusing experience hey but you know it
got here 22. so
win-win for me i guess thanks max max
max max i'm just going to keep saying
max um
um no but i'm i'm doing a creative
writing uh uh workshop at ucla uh right
now
um
uh concentration yeah yeah so i'm almost
done i'm graduating and i'm glad i got
to finally do like a workshop because i
do want to share my writing at some
point
you've done two workshops before honey
yeah oh this is your third workshop
that's why you're a creator writing a
concentration if she's the biggest fan
of your writing she's the one i 100
agree and um you you like my writing
right i love it okay because i'm gonna
make some dollars off of it just kidding
also nadia is an incredible writer too
and you're all going to read her writing
someday
100 i know you will
jake is jake is really good i really
wish like he wrote this short story for
his workshop um and i read it last night
and i really wish he would put it out on
his patreon or something because it's so
good it was i like was depressed all
night last night because of his story
yeah but it's good because that means it
works
i am and thank you for the
two euros
and
max
what you think your bad taste
[Laughter]
so confused max right now
but this is a different max so
hey
that's freaking awesome um
i was going to ask a different question
but i forgot thank okay all right that's
fine no worries is there more like donut
okay
the hell all right we got chug
what is the greatest undertaking that
you've been meaning to embark on for the
channel that you haven't been able to do
yet
oh my god um
i have i have a lot of ideas some of
them are just kind of like meme ideas
that are like so far-fetched that it's
going to take like years
that'll
just be so funny um
i really like the idea of just um
i like i like the idea of like sort of
now where you don't really know if it's
going to be a serious video or not i
always love getting those comments where
they're like is this serious or not is
this real
um
and yeah i i do want to do some more
like media analysis honestly
one project i have in mind in particular
is doing like a full retrospective
discussion review it would take hours
of uh chuck
the show zachary levi chuck
such a good show
i just really want to do that because
that's uh such a good show like that
would be a fun video so thank you for
the question
daniel
oh man uh your proof to me that quality
content on this platform still has a
chance to write to the top you've earned
the hell out of this jake and don't ever
let the imposter syndrome tell you
otherwise oh that is really sweet um he
does have an impostor syndrome
i'm the reason for most of it well it's
because i'm an imposter
thank you daniel that's very kind
um
yeah daniel's the best like seriously
he's he's like gotta be one of the best
uh you know creators out there just in
in not just in terms of his the constant
quality but he's just really really
generous to
everyone you know like i said he reached
out to me when i had
you know like 200 something subs and
told me to just keep going and i don't
know if i'd still be doing it i mean i
would because you'd be forcing me but
but you know that motivation like meant
a lot like damn and honestly if you are
like a small youtuber
doing making videos consistently and
like doing that like you are already
um
doing like work doing so much like the
hardest part for me was getting 100 subs
and i think that's true for most people
it's really it really is the hardest
part it doesn't change i wouldn't
disagree
i would say the hardest part is probably
when you like reach 500
subs
that was hard hitting a thousand was a
big deal yeah
hey thank you
anakit big congrats on 100k subs for
maintaining this unique vibe of the
channel did you jump into donaldson with
gap cycle or have you read thomas
covenant and will you review more
williams uh 100
um i jumped into donaldson through the
gap cycle and not thomas government i've
been waiting to start thomas covenant
i'm really excited to start it um
but yeah like the gap cycle is a hell of
a ride i i that's another series i plan
to dive right back into when i graduate
um next month um
but yeah i really want to get into that
uh williams 100 i kind of i read
butcher's crossing first i kind of like
to not read the obvious one first like i
know everyone reads story i want to read
stoner but i kind of like i'm anxious
about it because i know it's going to be
good but i have these expectations so
yes i will be reading that don't worry
um
my writings are just copies of the old
testament
that's like could you imagine i'm just
like hey guys
new short story out
it's x it's called exodus um
is this your gal bra yeah brah this is
my gal
these are my gals right here um nadia
reading the super chat outlet um
yeah
thank you guys for like okay i'm really
behind on the chat aren't they
yes
all right all right oh my god i'm
getting you guys are so kind what the
hell
what the hell okay there's i'm like
literally behind on super okay all right
all right i got it i got it don't worry
all right corvus thank you
daniel green again wait my time has come
chat bully jake into trying one piece
oh my god we almost bought it when we're
in london um
it wouldn't fit though just like that he
stabs you in the back you know
starts out so nice
starts out so nice stabs you in the back
um
uh no read berserk um i don't know about
that did you see multiverse madness
actually no joke we're going to go see
it right after the stream right after
yeah nadia's making me even though i
want to sleep
i hope one day you will depress us all
with your writing jake congrats 100k
oh come on jay that's so sweet you
didn't have to do that that's really
kind and i appreciate you so much
jay is like legit one of the best
booktubers editors like content creators
ever like i i love your content i love
your channel with your girlfriend i and
his and his blog channel we do we we
really like what he's doing over there
too that's really good
um
we is this is now a mustache waxing
stream never in a million years that
will i can't even picture the pain
that would that would give me but oh my
god
to wax your mustache um immortality is
pretty cool yeah guys so i'm i'm a lot
did you see the title of the stream by
the way no what is it
i'll tell you i will be i will live
forever yeah
um
well you better if you don't want me to
haunt you as a ghost right at least you
better not die before me right right i'm
trying to read everyone's
comment i promise you i'm trying to get
to them but people are like donating
like it's really kind i really
appreciate it okay i believe max is next
uh sorry for the confusing message i
couldn't phrase my dumb show correctly
because youtube my house being mean to
you i think oh here's more money
be mean to me that's i don't care you
know appreciate that yeah seriously what
the hell man like this is really really
generous and i
holy [ __ ] this is
wow thank you
um
and
being a fan of the real time tv series i
hate how much i enjoyed your critique of
it many good points serious question
don't you think the big dragon reveal
worked for non-book readers so
um well you know that that's a great
question and thank you for saying that
actually non-book reader right here she
can tell you how she felt about the
dragon reveal how did you feel about
that
well so i haven't read will time now i'm
in a little bit and so
i like i seem to like the series a lot
more than book readers did um but
the dragon reveal i thought was a little
bit of cop out because um
naomi
had this night night
had sorry naive had different wrong show
um naive had this amazing power that
like was she like literally brought
people back to life right and she
literally healed people back to life
killed bunch of people all together
rand's power in comparison to that was
so small
that it just kind of like without
reading a book again i understand book
readers have different opinions than i
do but like without understanding the
context or the world building or where
the characters are going to eventually
end up i thought it was kind of
it just felt like so short like really
this is a dragon it felt really
underwhelming
so i didn't like it
yeah i think that's kind of what i
touched on in the in the review too like
that i felt like
it
like naive was a strong
person they didn't do enough to show it
it felt like it ran didn't earn it just
felt like it wasn't totally it was just
given to him and it just was like and
then he just leaves and then
and then like they just let him leave
and it's like the whole time it's like
you can't leave because like it's like
it's like it just feels felt very
convenient and it i i you know so anyway
yeah absolutely and hey ahmed thank you
so much uh this wonderful community
you've built i look forward to every
booktube video make thank you so much
i'm i'm always going to be reviewing
books like don't worry um
um
tarian wait this is supposed to go to
paramount plus can i have it back please
[Laughter]
um
darian is hilarious i did a video on his
channel he's so funny please go check
out his channel and you did not have to
do that darian but i appreciate that
it's really kind um but yeah i mean it's
he's great his future collabs with him
in the future it's a very funny guy um
and i just met him online so you know
you know it's real um
i'd rather you have this money than have
my wife get in the divorce you know i
appreciate that because
as we've established on twitter and i i
don't know if you all saw this but i did
a poll and it turns out you all want to
be called children of divorce i was
thinking like man carrying gang or
whatever or you know daniel green has
goblins but i guess you're all doing
children of divorce so i want you to go
back to deborah
they no they don't do you guys want me
to go back to deborah that's crazy
all right
[Laughter]
donation go burrs right capitalism
[Laughter]
man
that was also the video where i say
capitalism just like that that was the
easiest video to make and it has like
one of the most views that's always how
it is it's it's totally in inverse of
how much you put effort into a video for
the most part um
you know if you expect a video to do
well just that you're cursing it because
it's usually the videos you wouldn't
even
expect the healing death is my biggest
beef with the season uh
yeah yeah that there were way too many
of that and i i hope i did
i hope i would explain that well enough
in the interview and it was so dumb
because like at the very it was it the
last episode episode before like bunch
of people die
when they're trying to for the last war
that takes place and then my name
doesn't like heal them back to life like
it's like death doesn't really matter
anymore it doesn't really has
consequences so it's just like you can
choose who lives and dies um hey they're
asking if we're going to do dr strange
review you want to tell them
yeah so we are it's going to be in our
second channel it's called um woman
caring man yes
and it's actually the title is supposed
to be like both ways because it's both
of our channels so
um it's like woman caring man or woman
caring man like a man who carries women
anyway
that's the reason but
what the
hell hey thank you tristan for the five
dollars that's really nice
yeah that's very very nice really dig
your community voice laugh voice keeping
big music
hey thank you very much
that's that's really sweet and uh you
know
it's kind of cool that i get to like i
always wanted to do like short skit kind
of videos and i just kind of back backed
up into it in an awkward way because i
just was like doing book stuff and i was
like no it's kind of fun to do this
other thing so
it's kind of how it goes i think when
you're doing youtube you just have to
kind of like sense where the where where
you're what you can just endure because
it's just you keep making stuff you just
gotta make stuff that you you like to
make eventually
max holy [ __ ] last one
that is really really kind
i have the option to study for being an
english literature teacher but i do
not like reading at all do i hate
reading because i'm stupid
[Music]
no those who don't read are are among
the chads of our society so you should
uh treasure that if you have the option
to study be an english literature
teacher i do think you should consider
if you like
the daily
the schedule of like being a teacher you
know
like
i think that's really important if you
love teaching student because more than
anything it's about just like teaching
students and
and making sure their priorities are met
so you know that's that's what you have
to consider and also just like the hours
you know i always think about that like
i
i don't think i could do it just because
of the hours i don't think that's true i
think you could just teach and then just
act like you know what you're doing and
you'll be fine
um
can i do a playlist of the whole joshua
saga and cr there actually is right now
you can go watch the joshua saga i think
it's on on one of my playlists and if
i'm wrong you can all sue me
um
wow man your thing reacted much more in
my super chat is that capitalism did i
know i don't know well i guess i'm
reacting even more thomas
i would love to see the wheel of time
faulkner crossover that would be
beautiful um
all right
how much chuck would a woodchuck chuck a
woodchuck could chuck wood
you got me to say that i'm really
grateful and for that and the seven
dollars
um you would chuck a lot of wood
yeah
okay now we're getting to the part where
people are just telling me to say stuff
which is concern it gets worrying but i
will say uh this out of you know good
faith for the community and the fans and
the wonderful
uh morbius heads out there
it's mormon time
i feel like i
i have to replay that after this stream
is done what videos of yours is your
favorite i'm curious what mct is most
proud of that's a good question daniel
thank you and hmm let me put on my
thinking cap here um i don't know
actually
i like
all right
i don't know i don't know uh i like the
one where this may sound weird i like
the one where i'm the at the cashier do
it with my wallet
and like i'm stressed it's only like 25
seconds but i typically like the ones
that are like the shortest and i i like
it if i can just get it condensed like
really nicely
tuned and just like the joke is as fast
as possible like i just love when i can
get it condensed and it's just like a
little poem like just like a little
simple little thing
and then those are the ones i can
rewatch because i can i cannot re-watch
any video where i'm talking at length
like my voice is uh just nauseating to
me so
i can i only like watching the skits
what about you
i'm so surprised i thought you would say
the wheel of time essay i'm very proud
of that one but there i can talk about
the wheel of time i say a little bit
later because
you know it it's just
yeah i i mean i i'm very proud of it but
it's i i all i see are flaws you know
whereas the skits i can just be a little
more subjective about it
that's true yeah
hey chug oh again
oh man last question for me do you find
greater interest in the filmmaking
process or the english content which
it's based on
well
you like in terms of the the stuff i
make
um
because i've i started out like
filmmaking like i've i'm i've been
through schools and i've been been
around like making stuff like when i was
in high school i made like a
like a feature-length movie with my
friends because i was like a bit of
insane person and and that was kind of
like my obsession and so i love
filmmaking but i think writing is like
my my deepest passion so it kind of
worked out where like i'm getting to
make youtube videos and it really just
um
gets that part of like where i'm like
writing skits i'm doing everything you
know that that's just kind of like
satisfying my creative um
my creative things
creative thing that sounds so wrong
but yeah so it definitely
i feel like i'm getting to do it all
i'm getting an advanced degree and then
making 20 second awkward zeus gets
that's how it works
seriously that is that was how it works
and it's really weird because i
like two years ago like i my goal was
like getting into you know a good school
and then graduating getting a good job
and now like now that i'm actually
graduating with my bachelor's degree
finally i'm like
what do i do with like where where do i
put i just put it on the table and just
look at it like i don't know
it's it i think it's still something to
be proud of because i don't know if you
guys know but jake applied twice to ucla
first time he got rejected second time
he got accepted so i think it's a really
proud thing
i'm proud about that all right we got
some more super chats um how many oscars
for morbius i think best picture for
sure
i mean best picture uh director actor
yeah i mean the the main ones it'll pass
silence of the lambs in terms of the the
main ones um
i know i said the last one
i wanted to highlight this one comment
calling you a class trader for reading
donation
[Laughter]
guys i
i i'm at that i'm at this stage where
i'm like i'm a class trader now 100k
sorry no no i'm really it's just the
sheer
amount you know and i don't want to you
know i want to you know respect those
who are donating
and but i'm i'm trying to skim and read
as much as possible from everyone else's
stuff i i promise you
um
but i also don't want these uh uh donors
to
expire hello men caring
bang thanks for the michael morbius
interview it changed my life forever hey
i'm glad that it changed your life it
changed mine getting to meet morbius in
the flesh was uh kind of a
like a midnight mass level of
uh
experience you know it was very
inspiring so thank you i'm glad that
that could help you
how old are you a lot of people ask me
this and i believe i answered this
earlier i'm 50 years old um
uh no offense but you kind of look like
dr michael morbius thank you thank you
brother thank you that's that's quite a
sexy
yeah
all right
i think we're behind are we behind yeah
am i missing stuff yeah
dog
honestly yeah we're blocking sedonas
[Music]
i love my dogs
buddy is another side all right
warbreaker review when
um
this
somebody's been commenting warbreaker
review land for
upwards of 100 days i have someone who's
been commenting about the stand since
literally the beginning of the channel
these are the most dedicated but also
most
insane and terrifying of the man caring
thing
children of divorce community so
um i am inspired by that dedication
but it also
means like i i'd have that rebellious
streak so but i'm going to read war
breaker
i just i feel like i need to do
something special for it it's same with
the stand
you should read war breaker too
i'll break your war
okay we're um
i think i missed some others um brevity
is the soul of wit shakespeare did he
yeah that's that's that guy sounds
pretty smart did he write was he a
writer thank you very much for that
jake the poet ah that's sweet i wouldn't
call myself a poet but i would say that
i am um i i like to to to make i like to
spit water out of my mouth at the end of
videos
so hopefully that that qualifies
um did you skip some no no no i think i
hit those
you skip or okay yeah yeah
i yeah i hit those dog you guys you guys
are are are really like generous thank
you congrats that's really nice
are the narnia birth books uh worth
reading they were for me when i was a
kid you know and
hey much thanks to you you have uh been
plugging our discord
constantly uh in every video uh so i'm
grateful for that you guys need to check
out the discord i'm not on there all the
time but they're having wonderful
conversations about books and about
morbius i am sure so they're they're a
passionate group and i'm i very much
love them so please check them out
um
scroll down honey i thank you
well i'm trying to read some of these
four more billion oscars for sure yeah
yeah but i think those are expiring so
you have to go down all right all right
oh here wertzog is here working class
here more like ronald reagan am i right
you are right and you know werner herzog
speaking of
um
i like i like him
that's all i had to say people wanted my
movie opinions i like werner herzog
um
hey this is text yeah it is uh-huh
um
um did i
miss something i'm so confused would you
say morbis is really meditation on
communism and that's why our capitalist
society can't handle it praise be
[Laughter]
i do think i do think that jared leto
put something in there
that is very
subversive but i don't think it's
anti-capitalist i think it's plucking
his cult maybe
um
what book has
would you say has consistently stayed
your favorite for years late in august
william faulkner
i just it's uh
it really stands also east of eden
um yeah so there's that
um han sausage hey thanks for the 10
euros that's euros right that's really
nice
actually maybe in a couple of minutes we
can make our big announcement about our
life situation yeah we could do that i'm
pregnant
i'm not
hey thank you everyone for
the congrats discord chats rise up yes
um i try i try to do my best you know
with that hi from india hello um
the greatness honestly that would be an
interesting one one of my favorite video
essays is jenny nicholson's talking
about the avatar avatar uh
theme park uh section in disney world i
love i would love to talk about like
what are some of your favorite videos
because i am a huge video even though i
make i've made fun of them i only do
that because i've watched so many i like
this one and what is that
what's the secret of your mustache
there's no c it's literally just there i
i wish i had a secret but it's not even
that
uh that good of a mustache but i
appreciate you asking um say anything
anything you have to say though
anything all right all right i'll say it
i already said it um thank you very much
um
read some ken cassie uh yeah absolutely
uh can't guess you good uh when are you
getting a cat
eventually we will we will probably next
year so yeah
um
yeah i can't wait to review jro tolkien
that would be kind of crazy
um what inspired the channel name hey
that's probably a good question i can
answer um
uh there's a
it's so pretentious honestly like it
people think that it's just like a
random but it's actually the name of a
poem wallace stephen's poem that no
one's read um you could you could look
it up it's one of my favorite poems but
yeah that's the truth
um which video did you least enjoy was
the most difficult
oh my god this is the
that's the question isn't it um thank
you for that question
um
i mean yeah the wheel of time definitely
i mean not just because i was
up against uh like pressure to get it
done but i it just was something i'd
never tried to do before is longer than
anything i made before
i was really worried about how it would
be received about getting stuff wrong
so it just it was a total
yeah shoot nadia can tell you that's
probably it right
yeah yeah god and i had to deal with him
while he was making that she put up with
me so oh man
you guys should be donating to me
you really said like she had to put up
with me i
[Laughter]
so
uh
couldn't read currently reinforcing
mccarthy yeah i love cormac mccarthy i'm
so excited cormac mccarthy coming out
with two new books two new books
uh later this year isn't that crazy he's
like 90.
i'm so excited i'm gonna read those for
sure i love blood meridian oh why don't
you show that uh five buck thank you uh
arthur do you think i could open a
booktube channel just reading reviews
congratulations
you could do a booktube channel on on
anything i mean it really is all up to
you i encourage people if you like
reading i mean it's
i would i would say if you want it to
um
you know try to just speak passionately
like that's really any the most you can
do like if you're passionate about books
do
just speak passionately about it you
know talk about what you like to talk
about and um don't sweat the everything
else uh there's some weird synchronicity
going on in your videos it's giving me
psychosis but in a good way
interesting i'm i like to i mean it's
interesting to hear i'm giving you
psychosis but
um yeah i don't know i i sometimes i
wonder if people are real like people
are actually watching the videos i'm in
like a weird simulation and you're all
just like
you know like bots or an ai
but um then i just you know
drink some drink some alcohol
forget about that
but yeah
uh thank you for the five euros
um
doctor strange review time doctor
strange review time yeah we're going to
totally watch okay so let's talk about
our our little life update do you want
to tell them
we are moving from los angeles to
uh outskirts of seattle
yes we are moving to seattle we are
leaving the nice sunniness and going
into rain and going to seattle
we'll be moving on
uh in a month so we're moving very soon
it's going to be
stressful as hell and
it's gonna be i'm gonna have to try to
make some videos beforehand before the
move but yeah it's gonna be a long ass
drive but you know it's it's gonna be
good for us because we've just been
needing some more space space and uh now
that we're both you know now that i'm
graduating we can't you know leave the
city so
as much as we love we'll be both remote
yeah as much as we love you know being
in l.a just
we want to come back though
here
we're going to miss this place a lot
we're gonna miss late night food when
you can order things anytime you want
and things like that so yeah
that's right oh and then we're getting a
new dog
we are yeah we're rescued from yeah from
india we're rescuing a dog and we'll
probably he'll be he's um really in a
critical health condition right now so
he needs to be monitored with those who
are familiar but he'll probably come to
us um
around august or september so we're
really excited
yeah i mean i'm very
well you live in seattle hey nice
seattle's a cool washington gang yeah
yeah
i love it i'm from seattle so yep
obvious from seattle uh i'm from arizona
so it's going to be a bit of a
cruel
change for me oh but snow is going to be
so nice
um yeah no one actually uses an umbrella
in seattle yeah that's what she tells me
thank you oh my god so when he like
visited seattle last time
he
looked he had he like he looked like a
taurus
um
green is from bulgaria hey that's really
awesome
um
do you have a side job except for
youtube i did you know i used to work
different sorts of
stuff and then i
got it
when i got to school i i would do like
um stuff like halloween horror nights at
universal studios i think i've told
people i did that that's a fun
uh like
like gig that you do for a few months
every year um that kind of stuff but now
that you know with youtube it's kind of
like i get to focus on this now which is
cool
um
yeah you know the mustache is a later
thing right
what the mustache after after after we
met oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's a later thing
it is a later thing um our okay i think
i read all the super chats
all right
wow people are from all over the place
holy crap that's so cool
my joke do not steal wait i want to hear
oh i don't know i don't know
i don't know i'm not going to read it
i got you in reading that makes me very
happy if there's any any at any point
i've ever got you to read any book for
any reason please let me know because
that makes me so immeasurably happy like
that that makes my day when someone says
hey i read butcher's crossing because of
you or i hey i read some elmore leonard
like that makes me super glad so please
don't hesitate to like let me know and
reach out that
about that um
so at this point um
how was the school i love you i love you
thank you um
you know at this point um i think it
would be
good to maybe talk about
the um wheel of time video if you're if
you're interested to just i i just want
to spout some
info about
uh my experience making it and there
it was a really
i was just trying to get as much as i
could into the video to make it
appealing to those who maybe haven't
seen the show i like i said i personally
really i'm a fan of the book series so
far and the show while not terrible i
think
really lacked a lot of stuff that i
wanted to explain and explore
um you know that's all just from a
writing perspective because i'm really
interested in writing i i just kind of
wanted to see how that works
so
yeah that's kind of like where i went
with it people are pointing out some
really great you know in the comments
there's some great critiques of my own
critique so i really like all of that so
i appreciate that um hey holy crap 100
for a hundred so you can rent someone to
carry your things
i'm appreciating
that's really nice hey jason thank you
like uh
yeah that's really kind i'm i'm glad
that the the book content is still still
there i'm really happy about doing it
and yeah we're reading more books in the
future and i'm going to get nadia to
read stormlight
at some point right
yes when we move
yeah thank you jason that was incredibly
yeah so sweet thank you yeah
very nice
uh
yeah pewdiepie yeah he's the next
largest that's that's kind of crazy
uh you guys are just incredibly like
generous and kind like i'm kind of
baffled by this generosity and very very
floored like i don't um
yeah
this is this is very cool you know and
uh i just do want to
um yeah just say thank you thank you to
everyone who is is here who has been
here since the beginning um
it's it kind of takes a
a lot of energy to to um get the stuff
out there so thank you and um
dude just please shout out my name and
my year would be made your videos are
great
um
srivats
i think that's your name
srivadz i
am shouting you out if if that yeah i
mean
everyone's really cool so
i'm just really happy that like the the
community here is really nice honestly
sometimes people like
family and friends stuff ask me like hey
are people like mean is it like hard
with that like really not not really
like there are some people who are just
kind of like taking things in bad faith
but everyone's just funny for the most
part like everyone's really nice and
you know the best part and sometimes the
most frustrating part about posting a
video is that i'll you'll be up all
night making it then i post it and then
the the first few comments they put the
joke they say the joke that i should
have put in the video and i'm like what
the hell like i should have just like
thought of that but you know i like i
like riffing you know
riffing with you all um
congrats on 100k
um
thank you i hope that you know people
who like the show could still um
you know see some something in in the
critique there but yeah i definitely
want to do more long form uh long form
video essay kind of stuff like that
um
don't worry man you are hey i got you
read something with you this way comes
that's fantastic that makes me very
happy so i hope you enjoyed that yeah
that's a great book i read that too it's
really really good book do you read
non-fiction books yeah i love
non-fiction uh i haven't read much in a
while um but yeah there was a phase you
know you where i was reading like uh
i like david mccola you know very you
know nothing nothing revolutionary there
but you know i did like his book on the
great bridge that was a that was quite a
book i read a book on uh richard nixon
like a like a
interesting story like just about his
life which was he had a history phase
where all he wanted to read was history
books i'm obsessed with i love history
maybe you guys don't know that but i'm
really really into history like that
really gets me excited i love history
channels
um i love alternate history
there's this channel called talking to
history i really love
you know so
there's some there's some uh
yeah there's aspects of me that you guys
don't know about yeah
um
wow some of these questions i i hesitate
to read because they are questionable
but
um
i have not watched dark yet i think
that'd be good for our woman caring man
channel
um
i'm sorry i'm just
i'm good oh yeah yeah
so does pazuzu zoo still haunt you yeah
yeah i mean
really really um that's that's a deep
cut
all right where are we at
joe man sup dude crazy hearing big names
like hassan and h bomber guy talk about
you are you into philosophy if so what
is your philosopher
philosophy book um hey thank you so much
for for the five bucks and i
p people told me that they they
mentioned me yes that's very cool you
know those are i love hassan each bomber
guy you know was one is one of my
absolute favorite youtubers period so
um
yeah it is weird like when i when you
see comments from people that you like
really admire commenting on your own
stuff it's it's really surreal and kind
of like damn that's
that's weird but
i you know so i'm very happy about that
philosophy
you know i'm not super deep into
philosophy but i i do have like a
um
i do have an interest in it you know
i've taken some classes on it but
nothing
super deep i don't have like a a great
wealth of knowledge on philosophy that's
something i do want to expand my
knowledge on though
um but i do love history
um
yeah
it's amazing it's main carrying thing a
union shop i like that
it's funny hey that's sweet i love it
thank you i actually hate my laugh but
oh come on you have the best laugh oh
you have to say that honey no it's true
though she does
um
what was your reaction to seeing hassan
react into your work
you're pure terror i was so scared i was
so scared when he reacted to it i was
like what did he say because people told
me like hey you react i was like [ __ ]
yeah but uh he was very uh
he was
a very good sense of humor it was one of
the most amazing moments it was pretty
awesome for the channel it was cool yeah
um potato congrats oh come on well
deserved i know you get here and beyond
potato is
one of the coolest like incredibly
generous supporter of the channel since
a long time
um
patreon like thank you potato you are a
true um
wonderful
just supporter of the community not just
my channel but other you know booktube
people so thank you so much
um what is your major i'm an english
major digital humanities minor
digital humanities like data science um
aquas
hey man you're one of my favorite
upcoming youtubers and i watch your
videos every day i've watched your um
danny interview on a loop for the past
week i haven't slept in days please
[Laughter]
i'm so glad to bring joy into your life
and uh yeah that's good
um
that makes me very happy and pleased to
see so
yeah that
the interview thing literally just came
out of nowhere like i don't know where i
where i
why i decided to do like those fake
interviews i think it just seemed like
i no i remember because the first one i
did i wanted to somehow use the joke
doing your mom
and i was like how do i do that and i
was like what if i'm interviewing denny
villeneuve yeah and now
i'm doing all sorts of stuff with that
but uh
yeah i'm not gonna answer that question
um
how would your life be different if you
never tried youtube um well i'd probably
what do you think he'd be
a carpenter
who only
carpets cat
kennels
anyways
um
you know you could at least try to act
like that was funny i would probably be
you know i'd i'd probably be doing
something with he'd probably get his
master's i don't know yeah probably and
get some kind of graduate degree maybe
probably
yeah yeah
or he would be in marketing because i'm
in marketing
so uh yeah yeah yeah
but uh hey you don't know me hey dad
what are your thoughts on chaos magic
hey um
yeah so my kids are in the chat now
which is really concerning
michael is that you trying not to
reference them or you know make it known
that they exist but uh yeah
um anything that involves chaos i'm i'm
here for so that's that's my response
to that so thank you
um
it's weird nadia's definitely look like
she's totally embossed
you have no idea just wait till if i'm
like this live can you imagine how i am
when i'm not live at least because
you're just sitting behind me
it's fine i consent to her holding me
hostage it's good
faking reviews yeah yeah no they're real
they're all real um
would you consider reading a greek
literature or foreign legion absolutely
um
i really i really want to read more
translated literature like especially
more
new new stuff so
absolutely
um
what was an audio major same as him
english and uh digital humanities yeah
so
same thing same major same minor he took
all the classes because i graduated
before him he took all the classes that
i recommended him to take so
yeah
oh they want to see your left hand to
make sure you're not
you mean this thing
um
if you scroll down oh okay okay thank
you i'm so confident with this stuff
um you'd better give some of this money
to the cast of zoom actors who got
locked up somewhere i'm glad to see you
still taking the credit for their hard
work though keep up the good work i
guess
yeah yeah thank you
i'll give this this ten dollars is going
straight to robert pattinson because you
know he needs it
i think he needs it
yeah he's been you're right i think he
does
yeah yeah
the alliteration on the spot
um
am i on goodreads or letterbox i'm on
letterboxed i don't have a goodreads
well maybe i do but i think i just have
one review on there it's just a joke but
um letterboxed i actually have a lot of
films in there reviewed i'm a huge film
buff i love movies i'm a big film snob
uh anyone who knows me will tell you
that i am a huge film snob you'll tell
everyone that
yeah
still have like so many dvds i like
having i collect like my blu-rays and
criterions and like yeah i'm a i'm a bit
much i'm a bit much yeah um you know
maybe this would be a good time to let
them know that we'll get p.o box and
mario coming on this summer when we move
we'll get all of that done
merch yeah i mean at some point i've
been saying like it'd be cool to have
some kind of like nice high quality like
like a legit cool merch because i want
something i can wear and some people
have said it'd be cool if they had
shirts or something so
we definitely want to do that i want to
open a po box because
again people have said they want to send
you know letters or stuff like that i
think it'd be really cool to get that i
just need to
do that
um po boxes are super expensive here in
la so i'm i'm going to get a p.o box set
up when we move to seattle
um and uh how did you guys meet
in college we went in college he you
know well community college yeah he was
mean to me and i wanted to change him
because i'm damaged so
[Laughter]
honey
maybe you shouldn't have me online
we're married yes
[Laughter]
immortality question mark i mean you can
only you got to reach for the stars
right in terms of the mortality i think
uh more dog content my man i mean hell i
mean they're they're always trying to
steal the show on our second channel
um
when is there going to be a moash tier
on page uh patreon
that's actually not a bad idea i think
right now i have fantasy enjoyers
what i've and then uh
then um
yeah it's it's interesting what is this
here
all right
you have to read it
i don't have to read it you have to read
it read it i have three testicles oh my
god that's a problem honey oh thanks
yeah i need to buy milk have my money
back
absolutely but maybe not giving more
money will help you
you're you're
insanely generous thank you so much yeah
very seriously absolutely
seriously a big fan for a long time
though you guys always make my days a
bit better whenever it comes out that's
really sweet like that's that's very
nice to hear
uh potatoes has a p.o box as a window to
insanity so i've heard so i've seen
daniel but i kind of like the idea of
of that you know like
we'll be in a house we'll we'll have
empty space you know we'll have a little
more space to you know
throw boxes around if we have to
merch exciting yeah that's
i mean it's cool it's cool i don't know
it feels really weird like that there's
this many people watching and engaging
in the channel and like man i just feel
like
i feel like it's a new chapter and like
i feel very creatively energized you
know school is ending i just i'm so
excited to put all my energy into making
cool just like
analytical stuff but also just like the
dumbest [ __ ] you've ever seen in
your life like i'm so excited
i'm so ready
um who's a favorite author from
classical western literature
um i have no clue honestly
um
huge respect for being a blu-ray dvd man
considering legit merch um
truly a man of culture i am you know i'm
sitting here with my seven samurai
blu-ray blu-ray pack you know
sipping my coffee but yeah i i like
because when you have physical blu-rays
like that no company's gonna take it's
not gonna change streaming service you
know they can't take it out of your
account you know it's there forever you
know it's it's not going anywhere unless
someone steals it i guess
um
hi guys how you doing
doing good
i promise you she has not
[Laughter]
you know that's a lot of damage
i shouldn't have said that
i know it's funny chug again
i appreciate how humble you've been i
try not to boast the ego too much but
you've been very inspiring me to help
you that's really i mean in terms of ego
it's that i can't imagine my ego being
at a more inflated
level right now so especially with all
of you just being oh my god it is
inflamed [ __ ]
she can tell you i mean i put on an act
on stream i'm just like oh i'm so humble
i'm so humble but afterwards i'm just
like give him my food
carry me to the bathroom what
carry me
i'm like i carry things so you carry me
yeah yeah yeah
is this
hey love the skits and book reviews what
is your favorite science fiction book
movie series and why is it star trek
is this
the is this real is this real lemonade
can you guys verify that is insane do
you know you know lemono's channel no
one of my absolute favorite content
creators ooh
of all time so that that's insane if
this is
that's awesome hey thank you so much for
watching i had no idea you you watched
so i appreciate it i love your stuff
um
yeah so my favorite science fiction
i i do enjoy star trek but only star
trek into darkness
please don't hate me i'm kidding i'm
kidding i swear to god i'm kidding i
know this is um
but seriously thank you for that
and uh but honestly my favorite i love i
i i'm obsessed with star wars
so yeah
yeah but i'm also i also hate it
oh yeah we like star trek but i i would
say like growing up star wars was more
of the priority yeah
yeah but the last movie ruined it for
him yeah yeah
uh what is this one of the king man
[Laughter]
which is why now you know the
inspiration for our second channel you
watched uh let me knows video on um
on the guy who jumped out of the plane
right
i feel like you did
i did yeah
that was a really good video
oh my god yes like your channel yeah
very very good channel
uh what about prequels and new star wars
man i'm still waiting for each bomber
guy to do his uh his full prequel
rundown because i want to hear his
arguments for that but um the new star
wars i do like the last jedi i will
defend the last jedi i'm one of those
people um and i do think that the rise
of skywalker was the worst thing i've
ever seen in my life it wasn't the worst
it was the worst if like ben didn't die
it wouldn't have been the worst
um
uh no bro no question you can't read
my logo and you make home depot job
better even though i'm quitting in a
week
good okay
all right i won't read your logo
i'm glad i'm making your home depot job
better you are doing god's work at home
deep like that's that's got to be a
tough ass job like seriously yeah you
know so respect i interviewed almost
like a while ago for a job where i would
have to work for a brand that wasn't
home depot so i would have to go to home
depot quite a bit and yeah i'm glad i
didn't get that one
uh you read butcher's crossing thanks to
me hell yeah that's sweet i love that
thank you
um
hey adequate emily i hate phantom menace
more
i can't lie uh yeah hey adequate emily
she has an amazing channel you guys
should uh check it out um
great like very very classy very good
and thoroughly researched video essays
so seriously
uh i really like her channel um
thank you for defending the last jedi
people give that movie too much hate
actually try to do something new and
interesting but just guys
um
yeah you know i really like i really
like it
and um
i know i know i i can't help it i just
thought
i liked where they took it
but i do think that it was totally not
fit for that that trilogy it just was
not the right fit
um
herniver it's like hey once again
uh
five dollars for liking star wars the
last jedi in a reiki of paul mccarty's
albums i'll regret this
[Laughter]
oh my god i would love to do a ranking
of paul mccartney's albums i i love paul
mccartney and i've been getting it you
know there's this what's his name
[Laughter]
i will i will just like spam that
temporary secretary just to piss nadia
off yeah uh but she spams um um what's
the song you play are you serious do you
want me to play no no no not for because
of content strike well i'll play it for
you ten times after no oh okay we'll
talk about david boy david bowie
yeah we'll talk about it it's too
traumatizing but um
yeah paul mccartney's albums ram is like
one of my favorite albums of all time
um so there's that it's called under
pressure
under pressure she plays out all the
time because we're all under pressure
you know and why can't we just give love
the second chance
you know
um yeah yeah
but uh
yeah thank you thank you verner herzog
by the way werner herzog um i i'm like a
i'm a huge herzog fan fanboy so
last jedi wasn't the worst i love
fitzgeraldo this girl is a great movie
man um
and grizzly man you like grizzly man
right i like grizzly man so much that i
went vegan
yeah
spiderman versus db cooper who would win
in a fight
i'm gonna say probably the guy who who
survived jumping out of a
the back of a plane like that
um
why do a hot tub stream at 200k if my
body's in shape you know if i've got
if i can
um opinion on youtube shorts i don't
really have an opinion i don't know i i
do i feel like
i like them because i watch them a lot i
i mean i feel like there's a there's
definitely a place for them but it also
feels like well you can go to
tiktok you can go to you know like
instagram it's the same thing just like
a different area what i like about
youtube is that it's fundamentally a
different experience you know it's about
like the the thumbnails and engaging
with the the
content and picking it out yourself
and i think i just kind of like that
experience more than it the algorithm
feeding it to you
so
i personally don't i don't know if i'll
ever do youtube shorts
but you know i we probably will do
youtube shorts in our second channel
yeah i mean i don't know i feel like
there's there's a place for them but
it's just not where my interest is that
at the moment um
how are some cosplay to be on the screen
i'm literally just uh randomly you know
uh when i see them you know because i'm
trying to keep moving
um
the man
please drink some water oh i don't know
if that was directed at me
um
oh my lord why did i click on that okay
uh thoughts on taylor swift
famous
you must pronounce david bowie
[Laughter]
i don't
i don't know why i did that uh what
camera do you use i use one i've had it
for forever but it's like uh nadia
actually got me a new one
for my birthday really sweet so um
but i can i can cover that maybe in
another video just like uh i i don't
have crazy uh a crazy setup because i
have to constantly move it around but um
i'm my brain is stalling
here let me help you out
okay
all right all right
uh rosie you dodged a bullet not working
for home depot i now have a question do
you think you'll do any music music
review content i love oh well thank you
and
yeah i mean i'm glad that you're able to
get out of there but um
music review probably not i don't think
my
opinions on music are particularly
contemporary i don't listen to any new
music
i have this feeling that people people
have like a limited capacity for their
like passions and i feel like i've
i've developed passions for like movies
books history like they're
like those are i'm really invested in to
me music is so
beyond it's just pure relaxation like i
i don't even judge my own music taste
and i have some crappy music taste but
it's just like comfort food you know
like i'm very much like it's just what i
like and i don't really think about it
too much so i don't think i would
i will say that the electric light
orchestra is my favorite band of all
time so do you feel like if you were to
do reviews about music then you would
like start to hate music because that
was true maybe i don't know i
i feel like i
i don't know i just don't have
the i don't know something about it it's
just like
and it's very personal
you know music is personal for everyone
and i just don't really have the
language to critique it and
formulate complex opinions on it i don't
know i just feel like it's reserved for
other stuff that i'm more interested in
um
i now have four testicles
[Laughter]
i want your dog
oh sorry yeah
yeah she looks so cute i didn't even
realize like she's been back there
sleeping she's so adorable she is um our
baby
um
oh emily yeah you use a canon
t15 those are yeah canon i think the one
you got me was a canon um i i have a
canon like handycam like stabilized um
4k one which is pretty good um but
honestly like my processing situation
with editing isn't
very
strong so i try to
i try to you know um
make sure my video quality isn't too
high because then it's a kind of a pain
in the ass to edit um
so
we're gonna change that when we move so
that we can have the space and the tools
you know eventually too yeah can you an
audio play an instrument this may be
another reason why i'm not super
interested in um
like critiquing and talking about music
because i've played instruments ever
since i was a kid i played piano for a
long time you know um
for many many years and then i i played
trumpet i was a band kid i was in the
marching band i played trumpet i played
uh tuba
brass instruments you know he played his
voice whatever they needed
no well not really i was i was such a i
was a major geek in in band one day i'll
i'll show you all my what i looked like
in high school
i think that'd be pretty funny did you
play an instrument i was in concert
choir yes you were um and so i did a lot
of concert choir but i mean i know like
elementary level piano
i can play a song very very well in the
piano like i'm like an expert at playing
one song
um
if you haven't said this already what
made you decide to start a youtube
channel um i threatened him and told him
i'll leave him
no well at the store he wanted to
impress deborah yeah
no i
it's something i knew i wanted to do and
i i was
the hardest thing i think for anyone
who's starting a youtube channel is just
getting the confidence to think hey i
can i can make something and it's also
getting over your self-consciousness
because most people don't really care
like to be to tell you the truth when
you start out you're way more concerned
about how you look then like now i
really don't give a [ __ ] like i i'm i
feel very open and comfortable just like
talking to this amount of people and
putting videos out i get way less
nervous because i've just made a bunch
of videos now but when i started i was
terrified about how i looked how i
talked about everything but that just
changes over time i guess so the main
thing is just the confidence and i was
like i just need to make videos you
encouraged me because i i did a like a
book video i think it was on
way of kings
and i was inspired by daniel green and i
was like hey you know maybe i should try
doing something like this and you just
said hey if you do this every week it's
just going to start growing and that's
what happened and i started doing two
times a week and i started doing three
times a week yeah and i just haven't
quit so that's that's it's just a a long
distance run it's just if you just keep
doing it well he made a video his first
video he made a video and it was really
i thought it was really well done and
then he for a whole year it was kind of
like i knew that he wanted to do it but
it was just more fear so then once he
started to do it it was just like
repetition
mm-hmm
um
oh yeah i just noticed a dog
love him
love stephen king how many dogs do you
have two but we're going to be getting
our third dog once we move to seattle um
once he can travel from from india
um
if you're reading this um
you use camera
band kids rise up hell yeah
i'm i feel like i'm missing
um
yeah oh there it is
darian
um
do you want to trade pokemon later i
just got a box of capri suns and i
needed
a few if you say no we're not friends
anymore
darion i will trade pokemon cards with
you whenever you want just let me know
but
please please whatever you do um
don't don't make a scene like you did
last time you know i literally was not
trying to steal your cards we agreed on
that trade and you just like got mad you
told the teacher so
please
just be mature next time thank you um
again go watch daria's channel i beg you
we we did a funny we we did the funny
together on his channel um
i read dune but it's clearly star wars
i'm such an outsider
probably the only one who watched all
star 9 star wars movies
10 euros to say that
i appreciate the dedication but man
funny um
new vids uh hilarious by the way thank
you
uh thank you about that
donald green is an inspiration to us all
he seriously is yeah
um yeah
those greens
what's the longest amount of time you
spent on the toilet um until my legs
fell asleep probably you know you get on
your phone just kind of three hours
for you
um
yeah maybe
um
i don't know why i'm lingering so long
on that question i'm really thinking
about it
um
thoughts on booktalk and would you start
one yeah you know with time i don't know
it's all about time management and like
at the moment i'm just more interested
in
focusing on youtube
you know and uh and doing that and uh
and writing and like that's a big thing
i just want to work on my writing after
i graduate well you did book reviews you
do book reviews on the second channel
well yeah of course of course but like
tick tock book reviews are like really
short succinct and um oh okay that's
kind of different kind of thing i think
they're cool
um oh by the way overly average ben has
a great um booktube channel please check
him out he's hilarious and a lovely
person
uh
how much does jake pay you to write his
videos i mean i i i guess i steal them
technic i steal your ideas for the most
part should have gotten a prenup
this is a this is a horror story
get pre-nubs
do not do not settle for anything less
than a prenup i can't wait for half of
this video to be like clipped out of
context it's going to be really nice
[Laughter]
he tricked me into marrying him without
a prenup okay
um
what's your favorite food what is your
favorite food
oh my god it varies i don't have one
favorite food right now it's a cruiser
pizza cruiser pizza there's this vegan
uh pizza place here in l.a we're we're
gonna miss that we really like yeah um
yeah i love we love pizza what do you
what's yours
god it changes all the time yeah i'm
kind of i don't know i like mama
oh that's nepali food by the
her mom makes the best mama yeah my
mom's gonna be really happy you said
that
if she's watching i love you
she's the best she is yeah supports the
channel 100 wonderful from day one very
they want all you know all my wonderful
all our family is wonderful
uh yeah seriously
so
i you've been here since you're
subscribed that that's really crazy
wow
wait zero subs are you saying you didn't
subscribe
you just outed yourself my god were you
waiting till see who subscribes for you
to subscribe
uh-huh yeah
yeah overly average ben is awesome
um
so what was the order
order of the events first she married
you or first you stole your ideas
um you know he stole my ideas a long
time ago but i again am damaged i
thought he would change
and thought
putting a ring on his finger would do
that sadly it did not do it surprisingly
hey uh do you guys want to see something
cool i'm going to show them buddy
yeah that's cool all right so don't the
sleeping be very quiet don't wake him he
gets startled very easily
okay
hey
oh okay i startled him
it's probably because you were being
like weird don't start on him and he's
like what what what are you guys doing
you're a good boy
i know i know he's such a cutie he
really is he's he's changed our lives
for so much better both of them have
some
uh
yeah hey thank you that's really kind
i'm very i'm incredibly grateful for
where i'm at right now you know but it
literally it would have never happened
without
nadia's support 100 like she's
she's the the reason why i'm doing this
why i pursued any of my goals why i'm
where i'm at now in my life she really
is the most amazing sport of human being
i could have ever asked for i'm beyond
incredibly grateful so
yeah i just have to say that and if you
guys want to know tips and tricks um
knives
um hide it under the pillow hide it
under
the books and everything else and
whenever they say about giving up you
show them that sharpness of the knife
and almost act like it pricked you and
then you know that's a
that helps
what am i doing i'm gonna cancel you
i need to be less myself
no it's good
she doesn't know how to take a
compliment it's fine yeah she gets
uncomfortable when i get all night
[Laughter]
um i'm still reading the dark tower
don't yeah absolutely um again like with
school i plan on finishing that asap
because i'm almost done i'm in the
middle of song of susana which i'm
actually quite enjoying
um
the jared leto cult i don't really know
that much about it i just know it for me
and purposes but it's
it's weird right like it's really weird
i think you're kind of the uh the one
all into cults so you maybe know more
about it than i do yes
um although i don't know about the jared
leto cults last calls that i heard of is
scientology
but if there's any scientologist there i
do not think you're a cult i'm so sorry
please don't come after me
i did not mean that i did not mean that
i did not mean that get that i did not
mean that
how much more a school are you playing
so yeah i'm graduating in literally a
month i have one month left i have
senioritis like you'd never believe
we're also moving in a month so very
busy very stressful moment but we're
trying to he gets done with his last
class with this final and the day after
we're moving so it's going to be a
pretty stressful busy month and a half
for us have fun watching uh inland
empire i've never seen it i really want
to see it so i'm super jealous right now
um
uh
can you say happy birthday emra uh i'm
sorry if i'm pronouncing this tan river
emre emre have you pronounced that
are you asking me the worst pronouncer
happy birthday amber tan river for for
your friend happy birthday
um
red rising no but we i we got it we have
the book so that's a very possibility of
something i could read soon um
interesting question favorite steve
martin movie um
oh uh pennies from heaven this is one
not many have seen or know about but
really weird different dark musical
steve steve martin really interesting
movie
um tom cruise at the chat hassle
hell yeah hello uh all my friends from
india thank you for watching
um
someone called
getting cancel speed run any percent
um
jesus christ real quick love y'all hey
thanks
we yeah hell yeah
appreciate that
um i like your face that's very nice
it's you baby oh
i like his face too i think it's you
pretty sure it's you
all right um have i read pinchon
absolutely i have but i have not read
enough to tell you the truth um
so
and
yeah i mean how are you how are you
feeling we've gone on it's almost cute
almost 1 30 do you want to
wrap it up here in a minute sure because
we got to go see our our multiverse of
magic you know dr strange is really
strange when you're late
it's not even making sense to the movie
yeah
all right we have to use this money to
buy the treat for the dogs oh my god we
will thank you you're gonna appreciate
that oh
there's that guy
our cutie pie
he is like ah they're both so cute oh my
god
um i love you that one part in butcher's
crossing maybe we want to down a gallon
of water yes i know
visceral book and one of my favorites
love the channel my two red versions hey
thanks thanks for the 10 bucks really
appreciate that glad you liked butcher's
crossing and yeah that scene that scene
my god
you you should read it honey it's really
an intense book actually no there's a
lot of animal carnage i don't know
um no i have not read any uh daniel ski
books um
so yeah
yeah there's another dog hey
all right before we wrap this all up
oh we have another one uh
yeah
yeah absolutely yeah that was another
interesting
interesting change there
i don't know
i don't know we have to see i mean to be
fair there is
i'm i'm looking forward to season two
and seeing what they do like i'm i'm i'm
holding out faith i want to see what
happens so and i will be there watching
it with everyone else so um
all right well this has been a lot of
fun i feel a bit tired i haven't gotten
a lot of sleep so i think we're just
going to chill for half an hour go watch
multiverse madness and
i gotta say thank you so much everyone
and i i can't leave without thanking all
my patrons um
so
and i'm gonna say them all
and before i do thank you everyone for
watching you are all
truly fantastic i can't you know i i'm
really grateful that there's such a a
really wholesome community here
um
and it just this this whole doing this
like youtube thing is way more wholesome
than i would have ever expected i you
know i got the sense that there you just
be attacked all the time but it's really
not
in fact it's escape for him from you
know his attacking wife
[Laughter]
she's joking oh yeah i'm joking i'll
stop i'll stop i'll stop
all righty thank you david weinberg
uh ciao
oliveira
pete thoophy or ck alex salberg c bright
obsessed with books ahmed al-amir
richard jordan hawkins
justin l myers lucas rizzoli
gratrilla
ben richardson aaron laksh
arun lakshmanan i should have done
a check on the pronunciation here andrew
clarke jude anden
whit
wyman nate harris
austin williams classed one
feligund tl bainter
joshua
a you're adorable
logan welp
jared humphries boy boy
booty kumra jeff grezick
rachel m
joseph kimsey
hal andreas haddal
danny nemati gnome spren
leon o derek wiser
potato
nathan hole
leandra w orc parrying sting
levi johnson
martin
salada adam k derek hale jh videos lv
and crazy fan take
thank you all
you are all the best
and
yeah thank you for sticking around have
a lovely
lovely lovely day all right
thank you guys for having me and
tolerating me
have a great day bye